en medio de la alegría y los abrazos Los
viajeros que llegan a China celebran la
reapertura del país al resto del mundo
luego de casi tres años de cierre de
fronteras estricta restricciones y
controles sanitarios marcando así el fin
de la política cero covid
regrese esta vez porque Quiero celebrar
el año nuevo chino con mi familia Estoy
muy emocionada porque no pude venir a
casa Durante un año y medio Así que es
un gran momento para mí
la reapertura se da justo Un día después
del comienzo del período de 40 días
conocido como Sun la mayor migración
anual del mundo que sucede cada año
durante el año nuevo lunar las
autoridades chinas calculan que cerca de
2 millones de viajes se registrarán
durante estos días un
99.5% más que en 2022
acabo de regresar de Inglaterra para el
año nuevo chino toda mi familia está
aquí y han pasado tres años ha sido
demasiado tiempo estoy tan feliz de
estar de regreso y de respirar el aire
chino tan feliz tan feliz
en China el covid Dejó de ser una
enfermedad de categoría a para pasar a
ser una de categoría B desde el 10 de
marzo de 2020 los pasajeros que llegaban
a ese país debían pasar un control
sanitario para después pasar a una
cuarentena obligatoria de varios días en
un hotel designado
estoy muy feliz entre sin problemas
antes pasé algunas cuarentenas de 21
días y 14 días Es la primera vez que
vuelvo con tanta calma estoy emocionado
a pesar del alivio de la reapertura la
comunidad internacional se ha mostrado
preocupada por la rápida propagación del
virus desde que se relajó la política
Cero covid en diciembre de 2022 además
de tener dudas sobre la fiabilidad de
los datos oficiales de contagios y
muertes entregados por parte de las
autoridades chinas